we're gonna begin with our clearest
picture yet of Americans feelings on
this coronavirus crisis and a new CBS
News poll an overwhelming majority
seventy percent say that the top
priority should be slowing the spread
not getting the economy going and even
more say they would not be comfortable
with public activities right now if the
stay at home restrictions were lifted
listen to these numbers seventy-one
percent said they would not be
comfortable with going to a bar or a
restaurant 85 percent would not be
comfortable getting on an airplane
Anthony Gael most Americans are not
happy with the country's response to the
crisis so far according to the poll 57%
say it's going badly the poll also
showed state and local officials are
getting higher marks than the president
even as governors faced some tough
decisions
mark Strassmann is in Atlanta mark with
Georgia set to reopen partially tomorrow
what's the feeling there good morning
Anthony very divided here the governor's
decision here to reopen at least some
businesses tomorrow in every state the
decision about when to reopen is up to
the governor and any decision is bound
to be criticized by someone but in
Georgia's case the Republican governor
was second-guessed by the Republican
president I happen to disagree with him
president Trump minced no words about
Georgia's plan to reopen part of its
economy tomorrow would I do that no I'd
keep him a little longer I want to
protect people's lives but I'm gonna let
him make his decision but I told him I
totally disagree but Governor Brian Kemp
will push forward with this state's
reopening some businesses have the
greenlight if they obey social
distancing policies although I know one
has the need to leapfrog over things
don't do that do it in a measured way
Georgia fails to meet suggested federal
guidelines for lifting restrictions
primarily a 14 day downward trajectory
of new positive cases
Florida doesn't either but some of their
Gulf Coast beaches will also reopen as
early as Friday we will do this safely
responsibly and based on the data in our
state Oklahoma also falls short of those
suggested federal standards but the
state's governor announced businesses
like hair salons and spas can open
tomorrow
we need the facts on the ground to drive
a lot of our decision-making
Massachusetts has seen a worrying
increase in kovat cases their businesses
are staying closed in Iowa Tyson Foods
suspended operations at a pork plant
indefinitely more than 180 kovat
infections were linked to the facility
we need to get a handle on how many
people are infected we need to get more
testing here that's critically important
on Wednesday Wisconsin also saw its
largest daily jump in positive cases
since the pandemic began there possibly
tied to a cluster of infections at this
Green Bay meatpacking plant nearly 150
people have got sick there tell the
medical community tells us it's safe
it's just reckless and irresponsible to
go back to business as usual
Wisconsin kovat survivor Leah Bloomberg
spent nine days in a coma
on a ventilator she's still building
back her strength and worries some
states are reopening their economies
prematurely yes you open up and somebody
is asymptomatic you know they don't they
don't know their carrier and it'll just
spread like wildfire after President
Trump's criticism Georgia governor Kemp
here I defended himself by tweeting that
his decision was guided by state public
health officials but other critics
included Atlanta's mayor and hundreds of
local businesspeople who are drowning in
debt they all agreed it's too soon too
risky Tony mark thank you very much no
easy options here at least until we get
a vaccine